[Music]  so what we will see in the next few  weeks is probably this concentration of  troops towards donbass  to carry out a form of pincer movement  or to try to join  little pockets of advance from the  northwest uh south from kharkiv  basically  down to this newly sort of formed land  bridge between occupied crimea  [Music]  as russia concentrates his force towards  donbass to try to hold more territory  inside of the administrative oblast of  bombastic ukraine this would create a  new geography a new military geography  where russia would freeze their  positions  what we see now is the  probable recognition by  the military leadership in the kremlin  and maybe even by putin himself that the  operation is definitely not going  according to plan  you